I am proud to stand here as the first
female
and longest serving incumbent of this
office
and I'm very proud of what has been
achieved in the years I've been in Butte
house
however since my very first moments in
the job
I have believed that part of serving
well would be to know
almost instinctively when the time is
right to make way for someone else
and when that time came to have the
courage to do so even if to many across
the country and in my party it might
feel too soon
in my head and in my heart I know that
time is now
that it is right for me for my party and
for the country
and so today I am announcing my
intention to step down as first Minister
and leader of my party